[Music]
[Applause]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
okay so far
hundreds of challengers not one winner
no one's ever caught us making mistake
because we don't make him we're perfect
yes tonight huh
tonight a fan named Nina sterner
says she thinks she caught a mistake she
said it happened during a recent comedy
bit hi conan my name is nina i was in
your live studio audience on march 19th
as you can see by my wristband and you
were doing a segment on Conan's video
blog called animals with emotions and
you showed an animal that you said had
been watching Fifty Shades of Grey by
itself here's a lemur who just saw Fifty
Shades of Grey by himself and you called
it a lemur when in fact it was actually
a tarsier this is a lemur and this is a
tarsier my friends and I did not drive
all the way from San Diego to LA to see
you make such a horrible mistake I'd
really like to see you talk your way out
of this one
[Applause]
first of all nina you're kind of
supposed to take the paper wristband off
yeah does not really thought of his
heirloom jewelry oh no no most people
take those off right away cuz they don't
want people knowing they were here yeah
it's kind of like getting out of jail
and still keeping the orange jump yeah
yeah you want to get rid of that yeah
yeah yeah
no you seem like a very nice young lady
and I hate to tell you this but Nina you
are dead wrong
of course that's a tarsier in the photo
do you really think I don't know what a
tarsier is here's the thing I wasn't
talking about the tarsier let me show
you here's a still of me holding up the
photo that night okay
there's the tarsier that I was talking
about now push in on those eyes push in
really close all the way all the way all
the way
[Applause]
the lemur was probably working as the
photographer's assistant just shut up
you're gonna get us both in oh all right
I don't know what your problem is Nina
the rest of the audience saw it and in
case you think I'm faking that photo I
can prove it's the photo I was holding
up that night
now push into the lemurs eyes all the
way and look who's watching
put a challenge still stands if you
think he is poor in that era on our show
reported a team koco.com / ha ha found
an era backslash Gov calm sort hashtag
stroke we'll sort it out blah blah blah
you